five nominated songs to tell us which  one you should hum on the way out of the  theater here's the only man with the top  hat white tie and Tails on his Oscar mr.  Fred Astaire  Fred are you going to the victory games  after the program yes but why didn't you  ask me before Bob my card is filled now  - to recapitulate the nominees for the  best song are Richard M Sherman and  Robert B Sherman for Chim Chim Cheree  henry mancini J Livingstone and Ray  Evans for dear heart  Frank of all and Mack David for hush  hush sweet Charlotte James Van Heusen  and SEMICON for my kind of town and  James and using SEMICON for where love  is gone and the winner is the women's  are Richard M Sherman and Robert reach a  consensus  whether in Oh words to say all you can  say is supercalifragilistic  expialidocious  that's a long car for that